[Music]
This is the tent for those kids me
ni
No one is here I ca
n't even connect to the phone
Yeah yeah
[Music]
What are
you doing teacher?
Mr.
Tara, I heard that Mr. Shiraki is also camping at
Lake Yamanaka.
As Mr. Shima said, I couldn't connect to the phone, and in
fact, maybe because of the cold weather, my smartphone's battery
was dead.
No, you can't say you're ready for the winter in Yamanakako with just that equipment.
Winter camping is really dangerous if you
don't do your homework and prepare enough.
I'm sorry
[Music]
I'm sorry too
I knew you were going to go camping, but you should have checked where you were going When you
're
deciding where to go camping, talk to me You've made
it to 9!
I'm really glad there
's none [music] I'll get in touch with Mr. Shima
Exhibition
jj and hot pot videos
Well, there are Japanese people too
tan
anda